donner la liberté à chacun d'accéder à
la culture et de la partager
offrir plusieurs billets aux ouvrages
tel est l'objectif du projet boîte à
livres
inauguré par le lion's-club d'elancourt
aqua li na au forum des associations
organisé le week-end dernier à elancourt
l'objectif c'est de permettre la lecture
papier à des gens qui en sont de plus en
plus se priver
or privés par les mauvaises habitudes un
temps parce qu'on veut pas qu'ils
fassent les livres viendront désormais à
la rencontre des passants avec deux
boîtes installées à la clé deux points
pierre et au village autre nouveauté de
la rentrée l'association family sin 78
créer un peu plus d'un an par christelle
6 l'air et son époux présente pour la
première fois au forum des associations
c'est une association qui permet de
réunir des familles entendant sourds et
malentendants tu pour faire des ateliers
enrichir son vocabulaire en langue des
signes
ces ateliers créatifs et échangent
parents enfants sont organisés un samedi
par mois
au total plus d'une centaine
d'associations culturelles sportives et
sociales étaient présentes